rescuing someone from a car fire for
real publicly shaming Elizabeth Taylor
and an onset dog who can't stop biting
people stay tuned to find out the Untold
Truth of ncis's Mark Harmon
Mark Harmon was a talented athlete back
in the day a native of California the
actor was a quarterback at UCLA for two
seasons and led the Bruins to a 17-5
record during his time there football
runs in Harmon's blood his father Tom
Harmon was also a gifted college player
having scored 33 touchdowns for the
University of Michigan he used to love
watching clips of his dad in action when
he was growing up telling parade I was
literally like eight before I realized
my dad ever got tackled because on the
Reel he scores every time he gets the
ball Tom Harmon later became a football
broadcaster which furthered his son's
love for the game though he wouldn't
start acting until after college
harman's time as a football star led to
an early brush with Hollywood royalty in
1973 he won a national football
Foundation Award that same year John
Wayne was in attendance at the ceremony
to accept the gold medal award as Harman
told Stephen Colbert it was an
unforgettable night for several reasons
unaware that it was a tux only event
Harmon walked into a clothing store at
the last minute and purchased a dove
gray tuxedo with a furly undershirt
surprised by his bold outfit Choice
Wayne decided to give him a nickname all
night he called me Rebel
why because I had a great tuxedo on
you thought you were some damn hippie
Mark Harmon ultimately decided to pursue
a career as an actor thanks to an
unexpected family connection after his
sister Kristen married the musician and
actor Ricky Nelson Harmon began hanging
out with her parents-in-law who happened
to be the famous TV Duo Ozzy and Harriet
Nelson Ricky had starred with his
parents in the sitcom The Adventures of
Ozzie and Harriet in the 1950s and 1960s
Harman became close with Ricky's father
as well and he recalled how Ozzy joined
him at the beach one summer when he was
working as a lifeguard at the time Ozzy
was filming a spin-off of Ozzie and
Harriet called Aussies girls one day
Ozzy asked Harman to fill in for an
actor who couldn't make it and he agreed
he spent his time on set following Ozzy
around and watching him work in the
editing room after that experience all
he could think about was acting he
forgot about football and began taking
acting classes before long he was
Landing small roles in television and
movies his big break came in 1983 when
he was cast in the hospital drama Saint
elsewhere
Leroy Jethro Gibbs may not be the
sexiest fictional agent ever created but
there was a time when Mark Harmon was
considered a major hunk much to his
embarrassment he was named people
Magazine's sexiest man alive in 1986. in
2015 he told people that he didn't think
much of the title though he found out he
had it in a rather unconventional way
the actor had recently done an interview
with people about leaving Saint
elsewhere but he had no idea the mag was
about to bestow the title of sexiest man
alive upon him he went to play
basketball with his friends one evening
and found that both backboards had been
covered with copies of the cover his
friends certainly found it funny and so
did Harmon the actor poked fun at the
whole episode when he hosted Saturday
Night Live in 1987 delivering his
opening monologue in nothing but a bath
towel and joking about a conversation he
had with Lauren Michaels about his
wardrobe and I said
the costume is degrading he said look
Mark tomorrow's Mother's Day and that's
something for them
though Mark Harmon may be the most
famous person in his family his wife had
a successful career of her own before
she met her husband harman's wife Pam
dauber is a retired actor best known for
playing Mindy in the popular sitcom Mork
and Mindy she also played the lead
character in the 1986 sitcom my sister
Sam according to people the pair met at
a party thrown by a mutual friend and
they tried to keep their relationship
out of the public eye at least at first
with dobber saying at the time we're not
trying to keep something secret but if
you don't want it totally exploited by
the Press you have to Harmon and Dober
made it official in 1987 and have two
sons together though dauber is mostly
retired she did return to the small
screen for a stint in 2021 when she
joined her husband for four episodes of
NCIS dauber told Entertainment Weekly
that she had been asked to do the show
several times before but only said yes
when she was offered the role of a
journalist named Marcy she only had one
stipulation telling the producers if
this is a romantic interest I'm not
interested
though Mark Harmon comes off as a
devoted family man he's had his fair
share of family drama over the years his
sister Kristen is most well known for
marrying Rick Nelson and being the
mother of the Nelson brothers Kristen
and Rick had something of a tumultuous
relationship and they were both drug
users for many years Kristin filed for
divorce from Rick in 1980 and received
custody of her four kids including her
youngest Sam who was born in 1974.
Kristen continued to use drugs after the
divorce and Sam would often stay with
relatives eventually moving in with Mark
Carmen and his wife Rick Nelson died in
a plane crash in 1985 and around this
time Kristen's drug use worsened Mark
convinced her to enter rehab and when
she came home in 1987 she found that
Mark was suing for custody of Sam who
was 12 years old at the time a judge
temporarily granted Mark's request as
well as a restraining order against
Sam's mother What followed was a family
feud of sorts which eventually ended
with Kristen regaining custody of Sam
and Mark receiving this rights though
you probably haven't seen Mark Harmon in
a movie for many years there was a time
when Blockbuster films were part of his
career path one such film is 1987's
summer school where Harman plays a gym
teacher forced to teach summer school in
order to keep his tenure Harmon spends
much of the movie wearing Hawaiian
shirts talking about surfing and trying
to woo fellow teacher Kirsty alley very
cute
thanks so are you
oh you met uh
well not a rousing success it did well
enough at the box office and certainly
didn't hurt Harmon's career the most
impressive thing about summer school is
that it was directed by comedy Legend
Carl Reiner who was convinced that
Harman would be perfect for the role but
the actor wasn't so sure and tried to
turn it down he told The Daily Beast
that he tried to get Reiner to cast Tom
Hanks instead and explained his
reasoning for turning down the role
saying I'm not funny
Harman shared the screen with several
big stars before he became one himself
in 1989 he starred alongside Elizabeth
Taylor in the TV movie sweet bird of
Youth and it was quite the experience
speaking to Stephen Colbert Harman
revealed that Taylor had it in her
contract that she would only work for
eight hours a day she had an assistant
with her that would keep track of the
time and when her time was up Taylor
would promptly leave the set one day
Taylor had been working two hours longer
than her allotted eight hours and she
made sure everyone on the set knew it
Harmon exasperated by all the scheduling
difficulties said hey Elizabeth all I
got to say is welcome to the fun Club
Taylor glared at him when he made the
comment but after that day she gave up
her eight-hour clause and stayed on set
for as long as everyone else then during
the wrap party which Taylor hosted at
her own home the Hollywood icon gave
everyone who attended the party gifts
but she had something extra special for
Harmon a solid gold watch with a
personal message and on the back you
flip it over
it says MH two hours Tick Tock love ET
while Mark Harmon was in a few movies in
the 1980s he has spent much of his
career working on various television
shows while working in television is a
well-regarded job for an actor today
that wasn't always the case despite the
draw of movie stardom Harmon made a
decision not to travel the world
shooting in exotic locations for one
simple reason his family after his
children were born he realized being
with his family was more important to
him than any job so he made a decision
to work closer to home he told CBS News
the story of when he went to shoot a
movie a New Guinea and he nearly missed
watching his son learn how to walk when
he arrived at the airport and saw his
young son walking on his own he told his
wife hate to tell you but I'm not going
to be doing new movies in New Guinea for
the rest of my life to be able to afford
the house we're in and miss all this
Leroy Jethro Gibbs is known for being a
pretty heroic guy but can we say the
same for Mark Harmon apparently we can
Harmon had a real-life brush with danger
in 1996 when he staged a life-saving
rescue right outside his front door one
evening two teenage boys were driving
down a street when their car crashed and
caught fire the driver was able to free
himself but the passenger Colin Specht
remained trapped inside luckily respect
Harmon saw what was happening and
appeared with a sledgehammer breaking
the window and pulling the 16 year old
to safety Specht told CBS years later I
owe everything to him spect suffered
third degree burns and was in the
hospital for a long time following the
accident only learning later from his
parents that he had been rescued by Mark
Harmon speaking about the incident in
2013 the actor was incredibly humble and
downplayed his actions but according to
spect however Harman is a true hero
saying there's no way I can repay him
except for Pay It Forward and I try to
do that in my life
though Mark Harmon's run on The West
Wing as Simon Donovan didn't last long
he apparently made quite the impact on
set Harman told the Chicago Tribune that
he jumped at the chance to be on the
show heading to set the first day just
hours after receiving his very first
script speaking about the challenging
but rewarding experience of filming the
series he said this train called The
West Wing is moving fast and you're
expected to keep up the cast of The West
Wing enjoyed his time on set just as
much as he did according to Creator
Aaron Sorkin Harmon's character was only
on the show for four episodes and his
Arc ends when he is shot in a bodega
robbery at the end of season three
upsetting his fans on set Sorkin told
The Hollywood Reporter that Donovan's
death was an example of something random
happening for no reason suggesting that
harman's character was literally born to
die Sorkin recalled that some of the
female members of the crew were
especially upset with his decision to
kill off Donovan making sure to let him
know that the special effects device is
used to simulate being shot known as
squibs were placed in such a way that he
could potentially survive the shooting
when and speaking of Harman supporters
on set Sorkin said they let me know if I
didn't want my tire slashed he'd survive
Mark Harmon may not seem like a jokester
kind of guy but that hasn't stopped him
from picking up a few playful nicknames
over the years Queen Latifah brought up
some of these nicknames when she had
Harmon on her show and Harman attempted
to explain the origins of a few of them
he told Latifa that he was referred to
Simply as the quarterback while playing
football for UCLA because his Deb was
the announcer and he wanted to avoid
sounding biased Latifah also reminded
Harman that he has been called a silver
fox more than once but she had no
response to when asked about the
nickname Papa Smurf he blamed his NCIS
castmate Sean Murray though he has no
idea where Murray got the name from he's
on here with you he'll tell you about
that I don't know what it means I don't
know why he did it but he did it and it
obviously made the Google list
when prompted about the two nicknames on
center stage with Michael K Harmon
admitted he's not a huge fan of either
one when Kay asked Harman what his wife
calls him Harmon responded none of your
business
Mark Harmon and his wife Pam dauber have
two sons together Sean and Ty his son
Sean has followed in both his parents
footsteps having become an actor as well
as a stunt coordinator so an NCIS
producers were looking for someone to
portray a younger version of Gibbs they
were in luck rather than casting an
unknown actor with a passing resemblance
to Harman why not cast his actual Sun
that's exactly what happened in 2008
when the first flashback episode
featuring a young Gibbs aired Sean
Harmon would play a Young Gibbs in a
total of seven episodes over the course
of the series Mark Harmon told
Entertainment Tonight that he's proud of
the work Sean does as an actor and that
he's proud of both his sons for being
hard workers interestingly enough Sean
Harmon was actually featured in another
part of the NCIS Universe though not as
anyone in the Gibbs family he returned
to the franchise in 2015 starring in an
episode of NCIS Los Angeles
it's no surprise that a series that's
run for 19 seasons and Counting would
have its fair share of onset drama some
of that drama revolved around Mark
Harmon and his co-star Polly Perrette
whose real-life relationship was far
from the loving one depicted on screen
peret left the series after season 15
and at least initially the reason for
her departure was unknown after rumors
surrounding her departure began to crop
up online peret took to Twitter to
explain her side of the story in 2018
via several tweets peret explained that
she had remained silent up to that point
in an effort to protect her colleagues
and added that a quote very rich very
powerful publicity machine had been
pressuring her into silence according to
the rep paretz claims Revolt around NCIS
star Mark Harmon and his dog as The
Story Goes Harmon and peret got along
fine until an incident in 2016 when
Harman brought his dog to set his dog
apparently bit a crew member who then
required 15 stitches Harman continued to
bring his dog to work following the
incident which upset to peret and other
members of the crew according to reports
peret then took the issue to CBS
management who made the decision to
prevent Harmon from bringing his dog to
set from Men on this created such a huge
Rift between the two that after these
events peret and Harman refused to film
any scenes together according to an
Insider
fans of the wildly successful procedural
NCIS were shocked when it was announced
that Mark Harmon and his character Leroy
Jethro Gibbs would be leaving the show
I'm not going back then
work well that too I'm not going back
home
Harmon signed on for only a limited
number of episodes in season 19 with his
character intending to leave his job at
NCIS in order to start a new life in
Alaska Gary Cole then went on to replace
Harman as the lead actor on the show but
just because Harman has left the show
for now doesn't necessarily mean we'll
never hear from Gibbs again executive
producer Stephen D binder told fans Not
to despair reassuring viewers with hints
that Gibbs may not be done Harmon
remains an executive producer on the
series so he hasn't left the show
entirely behind Sean Murray who plays
McGee says Harman still comes to set
often regarding Harmon's continued
presence behind the scenes Murray told
parade I really truly believe that the
Gibbs could pop up somewhere I really
believe that there's a possibility of
that happening none of this is
confirmation one way or the other but
it's clear that Harman remains an
important part of the NCIS family
whether he ever returns as Gibbs or not
though Harman has been working steadily
as an actor for over 40 years he has a
pretty good idea of what he would be
doing now if Hollywood hadn't worked out
for him when Men's Journal asked him
what he would do if acting weren't an
option he was quick to answer saying I'd
be a carpenter I tried to do that but I
just couldn't get hired like his
character Gibbs who builds boats in his
free time Harmon says he still enjoys
carpentry but he doesn't have much time
to do it anymore when working as a
carpenter didn't pan out for harm and he
went on to work at an ad firm where he
stayed for about four years it was
during this time that he got a promotion
at a sales rep company meaning he was
essentially a shoe salesman for a few
months he recalled the moment he made
the decision to switch to acting
full-time on the flight home after a
work trip in Boston he was sitting next
to a 33 year old man who was telling him
about how he was trying to make pension
by 65 meaning he would have to remain at
his job for another three decades as
Harmon recalled he was drinking his
second Martini by the time we were
wheels up he was miserable in his job
and he was trying to maintain the job
for another another 32 years I went home
got in my car drove out to the place
where I worked and gave my notice
[Music]